in an increasingly partisan and volatile
social media landscape
more and more americans are looking for
a less politicized way to connect
with friends and family if this sounds
like you
it's time to sign up for commonplace
a safe and neutral social media site
where users can share their thoughts and
opinions that can't be interpreted as
political
offensive or controversial in any way
simply sign up and select between one of
three usernames
and since pictures can easily evoke
human emotions
and be assigned deeper meaning you will
automatically be assigned a profile
picture
of either a lamp or a penguin the least
offensive of birds
you'll love connecting with fellow users
but
since the terms friends and followers
suggest
exclusivity you'll see upon signing up
that our
entire user base has been added to your
personal network contacts
now it's time to get posting
you can commonplace post or whatever
anything you want simply type up your
whatever
and hit the submit for review button
then
wait four to six weeks for our safety
moderators to approve your whatever to
the commonplace
just make sure not to use any of the
banned words
and don't forget to acknowledge and
re-indifferent
other users whatevers as well you're
well on your way to a safe
peaceful social media experience as we
collect and sell
your data commonplace eight users and
counting